this is the equivalent to particle
physics as any major sports stadium is
to any big sporting event in Britain
Wimbledon is to tennis in Australia the
Sydney Opera House is to singing and you
know this is where it's at it looks a
little rundown actually doesn't it I
think what we're seeing here is that
they focus their attention on the
experiments and that the people who are
working on the experiments and doing the
day-to-day investigations well they can
survive with the 1960s 1950s building
that seems to have rust above the
windows looks like in that good leaking
a little bit
CERN's way bigger than the Large Hadron
Collider and in fact it it dates back to
just after the Second World War the
first ideas for a European major
European research lab to look at the
fundamental structures of matter there's
never a Lupino builder physique monsieur
felix bloch a Prezy de la ceremonie girl
opposed gala premiere Pierre Dynasty to
European policy absolutely and it was at
a time when Europe was still recovering
from the Second World War things were
developing in the US and further east
and and it was felt that Europe needed
to be able to put together something
together not not least because they
couldn't afford it for any individual
country so they put a proposal together
to have a lab and it was decided to be
hosted in Geneva which was probably
maybe politically wise it was neutral
territory
it was beautiful area with the help of
you know people like Niels Bohr and
Louis de Broglie major major pioneers of
quantum mechanics they develop started
the the plan and it began with a
cyclotron being built and then that
moved on in the 1950s to have a proton
synchrotron being built and that's still
being used today then it sort of
developed a bit more and as part of the
Vaden rings to the LHC they developed a
super proton synchrotron in that they
found that's where the W and Z particles
were first discovered firing protons and
antiprotons around that ring
so in the 1970s they had the lek being
built with their high-precision
experiments that were able to uncover
the fundamental properties of the W and
Z this is where the Nobel Prize was
awarded for work done here at the SPS
the first evidence was in that tube
there that's now in this little Museum
this little Science Park where children
probably run up and down it
[Music]
yaagh ml named after Hubley's legendary
giant wife of gargantuan yeah that's the
first evidence for what would have known
as neutral currents which and were
postulated as being that would exist
because of the presence of the z
particle and they've also got the Nobel
Prize in 1992 for work of someone called
George Chopin who had come up with a new
class of detectors which went beyond the
usual bubble chambers and taking
photographs of particles interacting
with fluids and leaving scintillations
of light he came up with a multigrid
detector multi-wire detector which has
transformed the world of particle
physics that way more sensitive than
anything else that has been designed
what does it stand for CERN stands for
the it's a it doesn't stand for anything
as see erm it's II forgotten what the
exact Central European research Central
European nuclear research establishment
I think is what it's it's there for
that's what its meaning is but it it's
just Colson it's the words that are
going the other way around you know see
erm CERN is the only place I mean there
was a place in America that still left
Fermilab is is likely an equivalent
place where they do particle collisions
but this is the main place where you can
come and do fundamental physics where
you've got the facilities the energy
scales that you require you've got the
manpower to actually do the work do the
experiments analyze the data and start
analyzing the data
there are over on each of these
experiments there are something like
three thousand physicists involved so
they're not all here at the same time of
course a cafeteria be a nightmare if
that was the case but at any one time
there are hundreds of physicists from
something like two 200 countries
throughout the world one of the things I
find staggering about CERN is that is
the variety of countries you know there
are people working on color
collaborating together on experiments
from Palestine from Iran and
Israel where else do you get that but
one thing a lot of people seem to know
about CERN is they invented the Internet
yeah but a lot of people say no they
didn't the US Army did talk to me about
that
so Tim berners-lee who's in the particle
physics world is given the credit of
coming up with the world wide web was
working here he was working with the
computing section and he realized that
one of the massive problems you have is
how do you communicate all your results
to other just other people in the
collaboration imagine you there's 3,000
people working on this experiment maybe
you want to share the results so that
they can all begin to analyze the data
how do you do that when they're all over
the world and he came up with a
technique you know you can't just store
it in one computer and everyone try and
access that one computer and he came up
with an idea which was to have a feel
like a distributed network so that the
the data could be distributed around and
everyone to various computers and making
a lot easier than for people to access
it and he put forward this proposal and
his boss it's quite neat his boss said I
forgotten he said something like is very
ambitious but I liked the idea and he
gave the go-ahead for him to carry on
doing this investigation and he
basically Tim berners-lee developed a
framework that would allow that led to
the world wide web developing it was of
course something an alligator's being
thought up in lots of places you know
the military as you say in the in the US
lots of places doing it but one of the
key things that people forget about the
about CERN's involvement in the world
wide web which i think is crucial to
everybody watching it CERN decided they
were going to make this publicly
available to everyone and they put it in
a public domain and that immediately
meant everyone could use it and so
there's no cost to people to now be able
to use the world wide web and that's
thanks to CERN to what extent is this
just a this is at the Large Hadron
Collider and to what extent are all
these other things going on or they all
just little spin-offs of the LHC does it
actually dominate all here or it seems
pretty clear in terms of manpower the
LHC dominates you know
the Atlas experiment has 3000 people
working on it I think CMS has nearly
three thousand two thousand something
two two and a half thousand LHCb to over
two thousand people working on nearly
two thousand working on me there these
are large numbers of people but that's
not the only things going on and and
they don't rely on the LHC and for their
existence you know one of the most
famous for example is the anti hydrogen
experiment and that when it's already
causing real ripples in the world of
particle physics you know this the fact
that they've not only managed to make
anti hydrogen which they did a few years
ago but now they can store many atoms of
anti hydrogen for a long period of time
you've also got the neutrino experiments
of course that work where the neutrino
beams end up in opera but they're
created here at at CERN through the
protons that come out of the SPS
accelerator that doesn't rely on the LHC
but they've created here and then we've
got a number of other experiments going
on that are looking at different aspects
of particle physics and testing
different things to do with matter and
antimatter asymmetry possible
experiments searching for evidence of
new physics seconds beyond the standard
model
that go beyond the LHC I mean the
buildings that that people work in are
they could do with at a lick of paint
here and there at least the theorists
who work in these buildings over here
they're and busy calculating way I mean
the offices are fine of course once
you're in there and the facilities are
fine but it's true compared to probably
what we'll see in terms of the detectors
tomorrow if they they look a bit worse
for the worse for wear it's primarily a
lab and and so and it's primarily doing
particle physics and so if you are and a
particle experimentalist you come here
if you can you you this is where the
experiments are whether you're dealing
with Alice which have forgot to mention
by the way you know Alice is the key ion
experiment it's going to test the quark
a plasma idea and quack Hadron phase
transitions so
just just happen to forget it song but
there it is I mean there's just so much
if you're a particle experimentalist
this is the place to be if you're a
theorist it is a brilliant place to be
because you can talk directly with the
experimentalist but if you're a
cosmologists then you know it's great
because you're studying early universe
physics but you don't have to be here
all the time you can you can be at your
your home institution you turned down a
job here I wasn't actually offered it in
the end but I had a distinct chance of
that I was approached about taking of a
six-year position here yeah no regrets
no no regrets no wasn't my life Stern
all right